Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricard Lops, and
today I'm joined by Doctor Irvan Dah. He's associate
professor of psychology at Cornell University, and today we're
talking about his fascinating book Between Fixed and fickle,
Why Our Moral Views Keep Changing. So, Doctor Dahl,
welcome to the show. It's a huge pleasure to
everyone.
Thank you. Thank you for having me.
So I mean, it's not the first time that
I have a moral psychologist on the show, but
let me start by asking you this, particularly for
people in the audience that might not be familiar
with this subject. So how do you approach morality
and moral views, moral values from a psychological perspective?
So, uh, to, to, uh, see what's distinct about
the uh psychological perspective, it might be useful to
contrast it with what's not. What I call a
psychological perspective. So, a lot of the times when
we encounter people who hold moral views, especially those
we disagree with, our first response might be to
say, oh, that's wrong, or I disagree with that,
or let me convince you otherwise. Uh, THE psychological
perspective, what I mean by the moments of moral
psychology, uh, is that we, uh, are those processes
where we try to understand why the person arrived
at the View they have, you know, so where
did that view come from in their own life
history or historically, and how is that moral view,
uh, changing, uh, or affecting, guiding their, uh, emotions,
their judgments, their reasoning, their actions. So it's, it's
the, it's the time when we, moral psychology means
to try to understand the moral views of others
before or instead of judging them. And what do
we do as, as a scientists who study morality
from a psychological perspective is that we take this
thing that we all do, which all try to
understand each other's moral views, uh, at times, we
try to turn that into a science, uh, and
that means, uh, doing, you know, designing studies, it
means collecting data, it means analyzing data, and it
means drawing conclusions, uh, using more rigorous and resource
intensive methods to try to reach more reliable conclusions.
So, for example, you know, if I I have
a student in my class who cheats, uh, then,
you know, I, I might react, oh, that's terrible,
uh, but I could also ask, hmm, I wonder
why they cheated, why did they decide to cheat
on my test, uh, and then if I want
to do research on that, I might do, you
know, a study where I interview, uh, uh, participants
about Why they sometimes decide to cheat, I might
ask them whether they think it's OK to cheat
in certain situations. I might do an experiment where
I observe them and see whether they decide to
cheat. So that's, you know, what, what, uh, approaching
morality from a psychological perspective means for me and
also what it means to turn it into a
science.
Right, so, uh, but what are the most common
views that people tend to have when it comes
to moral values and whether they change or not?
I mean, in terms of the sort of folk
psychological views that people have about it.
Right, so obviously there's, there's lots of things that
people believe, as morality is something that we see
everywhere, something we think about a lot. Uh, ONE
particular view of morality that I'm interested in, in
this, in this book, is the idea that certain,
uh, moral truths are, you know, fixed and obvious,
uh. Things like, you know, violence is wrong, slavery
is wrong, uh, or, or that it's good to
help people, it's wrong to lie, good to be
honest. Uh, THOSE kinds of, of things seem kind
of obvious, seem kind of not in need of
a, a, uh, justification or a reason. Uh, AND
then, uh, we, but then we encounter people who
Living now or living, you know, a long time
ago, who don't share those views, uh, we can
think of people in the United States, obviously we
think a lot, talk a lot about the history
of slavery, so why could somebody who seemed to
otherwise you know share many of our values, uh,
practice slavery, somebody like Thomas Jefferson, for example. Um,
SO, uh, the, and then the to make sense
of This, and why is it that some people
don't see the kinds of moral views that, that
we think of as obvious, uh, people often resort
to what I call the fickle view of morality,
meaning thing, well, they must be blinded somehow by,
uh, amoral forces, by selfishness, by, uh, obedience to
authorities, by unruly passions, they must be. BLINDED from
these obvious moral truths, so they see what I
call a, a fickle morality. So that's one kind
of, uh, I guess I call it a story
uh of morality that is quite common both inside
and outside sciences, actually, this idea that certain moral
truths are obvious, and whoever doesn't see them, whoever
changes away from them or never changed into them,
uh, must have a fickle uh moral sense.
Right, so, uh, but I, but I mean, in
the book you talk about the ideas of fixed
truths and fickle moralities. I mean, do people tend
to hold both of those ideas and what does
each of them mean exactly?
Right, so, yeah, it's the fixed, fixed part is
the kind of the, the, what I use, what
I call the fixed uh uh view of morality
is the idea that there are these moral truths
that are kind of obvious and, uh, and self-evident
and unchanging, um, and the fickle part is our
theory of why not everybody can see those seemingly
self-evident. Obvious fixed moral truths. Uh, SO that's kind
of how those two ideas operate in concert, that
the, the, the fickle is a kind of an
empirical theory, a testable theory of why people, uh,
people have the moral views they do, why their
moral views change. So, you know, for example, I,
I was talking to a, uh, somebody at a
birthday party for a young child, uh, you know,
a few, a few months. Months ago, and we
got to talking about uh why some people in
this, in this country are supporting, uh, uh, voted
for uh President Trump. Um, AND this person who
is obviously a liberal, um, uh, and as most
people are in the, in the academy, uh, at
least in the, the social sciences, he said, um,
well, maybe they're just dumb, um, and that is
to me, you know, a fickle. Theory of, uh,
morality. It's the idea that, well, any sane person
would see that President Trump is, is a bad
person, you know, and if whoever doesn't see that
must be dumb or evil or, or, or somehow
otherwise deviating from the moral path uh for a
based on, on amoral forces. So that's not, that
was to me a very an instance of what
I call the fickle view morality.
Yeah, but the funny thing is, and of course
we're going to get more into that when it
comes to how people develop their set of moral
values and how they might change in different situations,
different contexts, and over time. But I mean, the
funny thing here is that people with opposing moral
views have that exact same idea. About people who
have a different set of moral views, right? I
mean, they both think even if they have different
moral views that everyone should have their moral views,
and if they don't, they're stupid or wrong or
blind in some way, right?
Exactly, yeah, no, you see this kind of rhetoric
and these kinds of theories of moral disagreement. These
explanations of moral disagreement from all sides of the,
the political spectrum. This is not unique to the,
the, the liberals, nor is it unique to, to
conservatives, you know, I think that, you know, when,
when I say when, when Trump and he says
things like that, there are these, you know, um,
that, that they're crazy evil socialists, uh, or, or,
you know, whatever word is, I mean, that's also
a theory, uh, of why some people disagree with
him, right, uh, uh. So, uh, I think if
you look historically, uh, among political leaders, um, it
is quite common to, to, to deploy these kinds
of theories, uh, of the other side that makes
the, uh, the, makes the other side seem not,
you know, genuinely disagreeing for sort of sound reasons,
but just unhinged in some way. You know, the
historian Richard Hofstadter calls it, called it the, the
devil theory of Social ills, meaning that all moral
problems are basically simple, and whoever doesn't see them
must be, you know, uh, driven by, by evil
or, or madness. So absolutely, it's, it's, it's, uh,
it's a common view on all sides of the
spectrum, and, and I think it's strategically used by,
uh, by leaders and by pundits and others to
kind of inspire followers to go along with them
and, and, you know, steer clear of the, the
crazy people on the other side.
And why, why is it that people, or at
least apparently people tend to not like others who
change their moral views?
Well, so, I think it depends on where the
change is going, right? If somebody, you know, sees
the light, and, uh, you know, starts to agree
with us, of course, we, you know, we would
like that person, uh, but, you know, if they,
uh, abandon, uh, a moral, or seem to go
against a moral principle that we think is obvious,
and we thought they were, you know, holding themselves
to, it seems as if they didn't really mean
it, uh, or it seems as if they are
more Moview was not really uh, a reliable one.
So, a very, you know, common, uh, way of,
of approaching, you know, cheating, for example, I mentioned
that earlier, whether it's romantic cheating or also, um,
student cheating is to think, well, look, here are
all these people who seem to value honesty or
who seem to value, um, integrity, and yet, uh,
when they have the opportunity to cheat on the
test, they go ahead and cheat anyways. Uh, SO,
uh, more, these kinds of Moral changes, what I,
you know, refer to in the book as situational
moral, moral changes, that can very often seem, make,
you know, morality seem untrustworthy, as if it seems
like, well, people might pretend to be care about
honesty, but in reality, and when it suits them,
they will go ahead and turn off their moral
sense and cheat anyways. Um, SO these are, those
are the kinds of changes when people sort of
deviate from, uh, from the, um, The presumed, uh,
obvious moral principles, uh, that, that people tend to
disapprove of and be very disappointed by and, and
can, you know, get disappointed not just in those
particular people, but even in, in some cases in
morality or humanity as a whole. Uh.
Um, WHERE do our moral values stem from? I
mean, do, is there anything innate to them? Do
they have, for example, uh, genetic basis? Do they
stem mostly from our environment and different kinds of
environmental influences that might play a role here? Basically,
how do we develop our moral values?
So, by, you know, around the, the 3rd birthday,
you know, most kids in, in all communities that
have been studied so far, seem to deve seem
to develop ideas about right and wrong ways of
acting. Um, AND, uh, you know, so, and where
does that sense come from? Well, uh, as you
said, you know, it's, it's, it's one great way
of framing that question is whether it's innate or
is it learned, uh, and The, uh, I personally
don't particularly like that framing as, as I talk
about in the book, um, it, because, well, it's,
it's often very unclear exactly what, you know, it's
supposed to mean that something is innate. We could,
of course, say, you know, innate means present at
birth. Well, if you look at a human neo
neonate, uh, you know, they, they do not show.
A concern with right and wrong ways of treating
other people. Um, THAT, you know, that sense where
kids start protesting against violations that don't affect them,
that they show guilt over their own violations, the
kind of morality that we really need to get
this, make the society work, are only evident, you
know, in the, uh, around the, the 3rd year
up to the 3rd birthday. And by that time,
the, the kids have had such a rich, uh,
social experiences that it becomes, in my view, impossible
and unfruitful to try to uh separate, uh, the,
what comes from nature, from what comes from, from
culture, for example. Um, AND, and, but, and, in,
in rejecting that dichotomy, I'm also, um, saying that
we shouldn't think of morality as something that's simply
inculcated by parents, as some, something that kids are
merely or, or incorporating, uh, from their parental views,
because if you look at the conversations and interactions
that are happening between parents and young children from
an early age, and, and certainly in the, in
the 3rd year, uh, they're not, um, Just a
matter of, of parents telling their kids what to
do and then the parent, the kids going along
with that. There are struggles, there are disagreements, you
know, kids sometimes thinking that they have the right
to do something that the parents don't think they
have the right to do, right? So, of course,
parents are very important for helping kids, um, develop
a moral sense. For example, parents can point out
how, you know, kids hate. IS affecting other people,
how hitting causes pain. So parents are very important,
but that importance doesn't reside in, in simply sort
of instilling, indoctrinating kids with moral values. Every human
through these early interactions and throughout our lifetime, we
have this ability to say, uh, despite what my
parents are telling me, I think that's wrong, you
know. And, and that, you know, talking about moral
change, that is how we can have these radical
moral changes from one generation to the next, where
a younger generation can come up or rise up
and say, you know what, I don't like the
way we're doing this. I don't like the way
we're treating women, or I don't like the way
we're treating uh uh racial um or gender minorities,
uh, in this society. So, The, the, where, where
does morality come from? It's from those, uh, the,
the kids grow and and youths, sort of growing
ability to form views about right and wrong ways
of treating others, partly informed by what other people
are telling them, but also partly informed of their
own sense of what kinds of, what kind of
society they think we ought to live in.
Right, but I mean, do we know if, for
example, aspects of our psychology like personality, uh, affective
psychology in the sense that, for example, perhaps different
people react emotionally in different ways to the same.
Kinds of behaviors, whether they stem from themselves or
other people and to similar kinds of situations. I
mean, do we know if things like that personality,
emotion, and so on influence the kinds of moral
values that we have?
Oh, so certainly, you know, uh, uh, lots of
those, uh, things influence, uh, our moral, uh, views.
Um, I was just talking to a colleague of
mine about David Pizarro who's done some research on,
on the relation between disgust and moral views, and
then it turns out that, you know, people who
are so-called super tasters who have these, you know,
really, um, um, acute senses of, of, of, of,
um, tastes, um, are on average, uh, more. LIKELY
to be, um, you know, to, to be, uh,
conservative or lean more conservative. Uh, SO just as
one kind of weird relation between a moral, political
orientation, and a, in this case, the sensory process.
So, lots of things, uh, inform our, uh, and
guide our development of our moral views, and you
could, you know, if you do correlations between genotypes
and moral views, you can certainly find sort of
correlations of that sort, um, but the, the The
way in which those other factors um are guiding
our moral views is never automatic or never or
rarely automatic or pre-programmed in some sense. Uh, WE
are, it's, it's always or largely happening to, uh,
kids, youth, adults, taking those experiences, and, uh, letting
those inform their judgments but their reasoning, about how
we ought to, to treat each other. So, you
know, of course, is somebody who is, who's uh
very uh open to new uh things and has
lots of good experiences with, you know, uh, with
new things, uh, might think, oh, everybody would benefit
if our society was more progressive, changing more and
so forth, um, so, uh, why don't we, you
know, adopt a more progressive attitude towards, you know,
towards political issues. Uh, BUT that person, even if
there's a personality trait of openness to experience that
pre uh predicts a liberal, uh, orientations, that Connection
isn't automatic, but it's happening because that person is
taking their own experience of the world and letting
that that inform their views about how we ought
to organize our, our social lives. Um, SO, so
yeah, so you're absolutely right, but it, it, it
matters how that connection happens, uh, and, uh, I
mean in the book I argue that, uh, these,
these changes are largely happening because uh people are,
are reasoning about, um, how they ought to or
how people ought to live.
OK, uh, we're going to get into that. So,
um, how is moral change studied scientifically? I mean,
what, what is, what are the best ways of
studying it?
So it, it really depends on the particular kind
of change we are interested in, uh, you know,
with, with children, if we look at developmental, uh,
moral change, uh, I know that which we, we've
been, for example, very interested in the, the emergence
of kids' views about, uh, about hitting. So why,
how do kids, they figure out that it's wrong
to hit others, and how do they distinguish between
wrongful hitting and high fives, for example. So to
study that, we need a couple of things. You
know, first, we need to know, you know, what
kinds of experiences are kids having in their, in
their everyday lives, you know, so for example, you
know, are they hitting others? How are other people
reacting to that? So we've done observational studies where
we look at, uh, you know, how parents and
others respond when kids are hitting, hitting them, and
how that compares to other kinds of violations that
for example, we're seeing that, you know, that, that
parents often refer to the pain that's caused, they
Often you use sterner tones of voice when the
kids are, when young kids are hitting versus, uh,
for example, when they're just making a mess. And
the next question then becomes, OK, how are kids
making use of those experiences, and then we can
go into the lab and do experiments, or, you
know, right now, for example, we're doing some studies
where we're showing kids videos of other kids hitting
each other, you know, sometimes we use real videos,
other times we, we use, um, uh, use, uh,
cartoons, uh, and we We are seeing, OK, what
are the factors that kids are tuning to, uh,
to decide, you know, what's the difference between a
high five and a punch in the face, for
example. Um, SO you can use both naturalistic and
parental reports and also experimental methods, sort of tease
out what is it that, that kids are receiving
and what are they doing with the things that
they're receiving to form moral views. Um, IF you
are interested in situational, uh, moral change, so for
example, um, That's something that you know the book
talks about obviously, uh, so going from thinking, well,
cheating is, is, is wrong to thinking, well, in
this particular situation, it might be OK, uh, you
can go in and, and interview people and ask
them, OK, you know, why did you cheat in
this particular situation? So like we've asked like to
students to tell us, OK, what's the time, when's
the time when you cheated in a class, and
why did you do? That, and did you think
it was OK? You can take that information and
you can manipulate it. You can do an experiment
where if they say, well, I, I thought the,
uh, the, the, the assignments, the exam was really
dumb, and stupid and pointless. So, I thought there,
I was not gonna learn anything from it, so,
um, I decided to cheat. If, if sort of,
if, if that is a factor, then we can
try to manipulate that and you'll see. Whether cheating
rates differ between sort of meaningful and meaningless tasks
in the lab, for example, we think we can
do experiments where we manipulate, um, the particular situations,
people are asked to judge, so we can say,
OK, are people more likely to think it's OK
for somebody to cheat when the person is asked
to do something, you know, that's really meaningless and,
and stupid versus something that seems like a really
useful learning experience. So, the, the, the methods that
we use to study moral change in psychology always
depend on the kind of question we're asking, which
change are we trying to understand here?
Right, uh, so, I, I mean, but when moral
changes occur, uh, can they occur due to something
like selfishness, unconscious effect, or just blind obedience? I
mean, do they necessarily need to change through, uh,
reasoning, or, or can it be just through those
more, let's say, subconscious processes?
Right, so, the, uh, of course this is an
empirical question. In principle, you could imagine that people
would change their moral views, uh, in response to
seemingly irrelevant factors. Uh, YOU could imagine that, you
know, whenever somebody felt a pang of disgust, that
they would condemn whatever action they were confronted with,
even if that disgust. Had nothing to do with
the, with the, the action under evaluation. So, this
is, there were some, you know, over the past
20 years, there's been a lot of interest in
this kind of phenomenon called uh incidental disgust, you
know, so you, you discuss some, somebody, for example,
by hypnosis, this is a work by, by, uh
by John Haidt and, and his collaborators. Um, YOU
discuss people, for example, by hypnosis and then You
see whether their, uh, judgments of some action, for
example, if somebody stealing a library book, uh, changes.
And, uh, sure, you know, you found, you, they
found in these studies, uh, that, uh, there was
a, you know, an effect of, of the incidental
disgust manipulation, you know, some of this has been,
you know, not been replicated, but, you know, uh,
on average, uh, there, there seemed to be an
effect in, in some of these studies. And they
found that, sure, yeah, you could, you could, you
might be able to push people around a little
bit, but the effects are very, very small, right?
You can push people on a scale from 0
to 100, you can maybe you can push them
from like, you know, thinking it's uh 65 wrong
to thinking it's 72 wrong or something like that.
You don't, you're not gonna get, uh, by using
incidental disgust, you're not gonna get somebody to think
it's wrong to save a drowning, drowning child, right?
Um, SO yes, these, these phenomena, these, these, uh,
amoral forces that operate at least partly outside of
our awareness, uh, can affect our judgments, but the
effects tend to be very, very small. Um, AND,
uh, when we look at selfishness, for example, there's,
you know, it's easy to look at, at, say,
at cheating, at students, uh, cheating and thinking, uh-huh,
you know, they're cheating because they're selfish, and they're
excusing their own cheating, uh, because they're selfish, but,
um, The, it turns out, you know, we've done
some research on this, that if you ask other
students who have no involvement in the situation, um,
where the, this particular student, uh, cheated, um, and
you think, oh, was it OK for this person
to cheat when their mom was in the hospital
and this instructor was really, you know, inflexible and
the assignment seemed kind of pointless, um. We get,
uh, similar evaluations by uninvolved third parties as we
do, uh, for the person who actually uh did
it. And what that means is that the person
who is, who's thinking it's OK to cheat in
this particular situation isn't necessarily being selfish, uh, because
they might well, and evidence suggests they would, uh,
grant the same right to cheat. TO another person
in the same situation. Um, SO it's rather than
selfishness, it's what, you know, philosophers sometimes call an
agent favoring prerogative, meaning the, the right to, to
prioritize your own interests, uh, over one's own interests,
uh, over, um, uh, moral principles that, that otherwise
apply, for example, the principle of not, not cheating.
Uh, BUT in what ways can we change our
moral views through reasoning? How does that, uh, uh,
uh, occur exactly?
So the, in the book I offer this, this
three-part account of how, or where, uh, people can
change their, um, their moral views, uh, based on,
on reasons, you know, the one is, um, that
you could, uh, you could change your moral concerns,
um, so maybe the most A dramatic example of
that is when, uh, kids go from, in the,
you know, infancy and toddlerhood, you know, hitting people
without seeming to care much about it, to, uh,
by age 3, thinking that actually it's wrong to
harm others because you're, you know, that, that, that,
that, that, that's just generally wrong. It's wrong to
hit because you're causing harm. Um, SO, or, you
know, when people go through a religious conversion, they
suddenly acquire new, uh, concerns with abiding by religious
rules that they didn't have before. So that's 11
place where somebody could see a reason to adopt
a new belief, um, and, and hence, you know,
uh, uh, in a, in a, in a god
they didn't believe in before, and hence acquire new
concerns that shape their views about right and wrong
ways of, of acting. The second kind of source
of um of, or locus of moral change uh
through reasoning is uh what I call connections, meaning
uh how we connect a particular moral concern to
a situation. Um, SO, uh, for example, uh, if
you, you know, thought that it was totally fine
to drive around in a gas-powered car and fly
around the world, um, because, uh, you know, that
you need to get places, and then, uh, suddenly,
you become convinced that, you know, actually, um, the,
the, this, all this traveling by gas-powered vehicles is,
uh, helping to heat the planet, uh, which means,
uh, that the climate is gonna change, which means
that it's gonna be harder to be a human,
um, you know, maybe next year and maybe in
100 years, but somebody's welfare is going to be
affected by all this gas-powered by all the fossil
fuels. And now, it's not that your moral Concern
with human welfare has grown or expanded or changed,
it's that you're now seeing um that concern of
preventing harm to others, uh, other things being equal,
as relevant to a new class of actions, meaning
that the burning of fossil fuels that you didn't,
you know, think of as relevant before. So the,
how we connect our moral concerns, uh, to new
situations is another, you know, locus of, of moral
change, uh, by, by reasoning. And then the third,
uh, locus that I, you know, talk about in
the book, um, I, uh, what we, what I
call coordinations, uh, so, meaning how people are balancing,
uh, competing concerns. So, for example, you know, somebody
could think that, uh, well, I, I know that
fossil fuels are, you know, harming the, the planet
in the long run, and, and that, you know,
they're contributing to global warming, but I also think
that I have the right to, to, to promote
my own interest and drive around, and I think
everybody else has the right to do that. But,
you know, over time, for example, Recognizing the severity
of the consequences to the, to the, to the
future, uh, somebody could think, come and think, well,
you know, actually now my priorities are changing a
little bit. I'm changing how I'm balancing the concern
with my, uh, our welfare right now and the
future welfare, and now I'm willing, recognizing the severity
of what we are doing to the future, now
I'm gonna, you know, make some more sacrifices, um,
um, because I think it's morally required, um, uh,
to my own welfare so as to protect the
future. So, uh, changing concerns, changing connections, changing coordinations
are sort of the three places of moral change
through reasoning that I talk about in the book.
But when it comes to moral reasoning, I mean,
isn't it common for people to sort of come
up with moral reasons for their behavior after the
fact? I mean, in the sense that, OK, it's
not necessarily that they've already done something and then
only after that they come up with reasons to
justify their behavior to other people. I mean, I
guess that. Also can happen, but I was thinking
more along the lines of, OK, so they, they
already want to do something, and then it's only
after they want to do that that they come
up with moral reasons to justify them wanting to
do that. So it would work as a sort
of a post hoc rationalization. I mean, doesn't that
happen at least sometimes,
so. It's the most obvious case of, of post
hoc rationalization, um, would be, as you allude to,
where people are asked to explain their behaviors to
other people, and they might have had reasons, uh,
to have for their initial actions that they don't
think other people will buy. So the one example
I use in the book is there is, um,
Is, is Mitch McConnell, who is the, who is
the um Senate Majority Leader in the US uh
Senate at the time, who, you know, uh, during
the last year of the Obama administration, uh, was,
um, asked, uh, to, or, or, or to, to,
to have a whole hearing and a vote on
a nominee for the US Supreme Court, cause uh,
a, a seat had opened up. And, uh, McConnell
refused, uh, saying that we shouldn't, you know, fill
a Supreme Court seat in an election year. Um.
It's, it's, uh, it, he was also then later
after this whole, you know, thing died out and,
you know, there was no hearing, there was no
vote, and, and then Trump was able to fill
the seat. Uh, McConnell was asked, and 00, what
if there had been a Republican president who had
been nominated, who had nominated a, a candidate, um,
at, uh, for the Supreme Court in the election
year, and then McConnell said, well, of course we'd
fill the seat then, and indeed, you know, that's
what McConnell did, uh, later when, when Trump in
the election year, uh, had an opportunity to fill
a Supreme Court seat. Um, SO in that case,
you know, McConnell was sort of, I guess, offering
a kind of post hoc rationalization, a public rationalization
for his action. But the initial action, his action
was not, you know, uh, unconscious or, or sort
of blindly, uh, selfish. He had a very principled
reason. He wanted to have as many conservative judges
on the Supreme Court as possible, and that was
his mission, that was his principle, uh, and he,
but he didn't want to reveal that because it
wouldn't go over very well, um, but it was
a principle he, uh, clearly believed in, um. So,
uh, the, the, that's, that's why this is where
I think the, the science of morality is, has
a particularly useful role to play because, uh, we
can study people, um, people's reasoning and people's changes,
uh processes of change, um, in context where they're
not in a position of defending themselves publicly. You
know, of course, when people are defending themselves. Publicly,
they are, sure they might be concerned with being
honest, but they also have lots of other things
to worry about, you know, the, the, the, uh,
you know, being, you know, on the stand in
a court, you know, accused of, of, of crime,
for example, is an obvious case where people have
lots of other considerations aside from mere honesty to
consider when they're deciding what to say. Um, AND,
uh, so, uh, That's why we surely, uh surely
people uh can say things that are sort of
inaccurate or falsified to the rationalizations of their actual
decision making, but that doesn't mean that their initial
decisions weren't based, also based on reasons, on the
other reasons and the ones they're divulging in public.
Um, ANOTHER I think useful, uh, case, um, Which
I think, uh, you know, is clearly real and
deserves, uh, study is when people have done something,
you know, horrible, you know, done something that harmed
somebody, sort of they, you know, like, uh, clinical
psychologists, uh, talk about moral injury, the moral injury
having killed somebody in war, for example, or, or
having done something else that, that's really hard to
live with, even if they thought it was just.
AT the time, the people may have to reappraise
that event in order to be able to live
with themselves, and there's lots of interesting research from,
you know, motion regulation and coping literature, uh, literatures,
um, showing how people can sort of reinterpret events,
uh, after the fact, um, in order to better
live with it. And I definitely believe that that's,
uh, um, true, but the The, the, the version
of sort of post hoc rationalization that was, you
know, advocated by many people in the moral psychology
literature for a while, where people were said to
routinely make sort of automatic decisions, unconscious decisions, and
then concoct a post hoc rationalization afterwards, that I
just don't see much evidence for that actually happening.
Uh, OK, so, so that view, uh, I mean,
just for me to get a better sense of
that, uh, that view is no longer, I mean,
supported by the science, or most moral psychologists no
longer believe it's true, or, I mean, what happened
there exactly?
So, uh, I think people have become much more
skeptical of it. I'm, I'm probably even more, and
have been all along more dismissive of that, uh,
because I never thought the evidence held up very
well. Um, I think you hold, and there's still,
you know, psychologists who, who endorse what I call
the fickle view of morality. Well, the more, I
guess I would call it a more pessimistic view
of, of moral, um, functioning than, than I do,
um, especially with regards to the, the role of
reasoning. So that's, you know, that's why I wrote
the book to try to argue against, uh, some
of these people, but I think take something like,
uh, moral dumbfounding, which was became a very, very,
um, Uh, um, prominent phenomenon for a long time
in the early 2000s, so the,
and, and then yeah, there's that example. I read
about it in Jonathan Haidt's book The Righteous Mind,
but I don't think it comes originally from him.
It, it's probably from another person that, that example
of incest between siblings, right, where people, where people
are sort of. Disgusted at the idea, but when,
uh, uh, they are asked why they have that
sort of reaction, they come up with reasons that
don't really make sense in the particular context or,
or the particular case that is described, right,
right. So it started with, um, with a, uh,
senior thesis study that a study at the University
of Virginia, uh, supervised by, by height, um. And,
um, you know, the, yeah, the, the basic, uh,
finding, uh, was, uh, allegedly that the people were
unable to explain why it was wrong to, uh,
for two siblings to have sex while on vacation
in, in France, where else, um, and, uh, uh,
and, uh, the, uh, the experiment, uh, stipulated that
these two siblings were using all sorts of birth
controls, it was virtually impossible for them to become
pregnant. Um, AND, uh, you know, then, you know,
sometimes people would say, well, you know, maybe they,
uh, the participants would sometimes say, oh, maybe they
get pregnant, or, you know, maybe something bad would
happen, and then the experimenter would always respond, well,
but actually, no, no harm ensued, you know, nothing
bad happened. Um, SO, you know, that was, you
know, made a huge splash and it sort of
strengthened this idea that people, you know, eventually were
unable to explain their moral judgments, even though they
thought that it was wrong for these two siblings
to, to have sex in, in France. Um, AND,
uh, but, You know, later research, both in conceptual
and empirical grounds, have challenged this, you know, finding
the right people can't provide justifications. It's very difficult
to get people to say that they don't know
why they make a particular judgment, and most, most
of the time they can offer justification for their,
their judgment. Uh, THAT people didn't actually believe, um,
that the act was harmless, even though the experiment,
uh, stipulated it. And also, you know, this is
a philosopher named Daniel Jacobson who pointed this out,
that the sort of the hall of the, the
setup with the experimenter, um, arguing that, well, you
know, that it, it was, uh, it was harmless,
you know, nothing happened. Uh, HE, he pointed out
in a, in a, in a, in a sort
of rebuttal. To this, this, um, dumbfounding phenomenon that
it's, it's actually not so relevant what turned out
to have happened to these siblings. Uh, WHAT, if
you're evaluating their actions, you know, we know this
from much other psychological research, what really matters is
their mental states at the time, and at the
time, they really have no basis for knowing that
this act would not cause irreparable harm to their
relationship. Um, SO, Jacobson has this, uh, example, this
thought experiment where, you know, it talks about this
couple who decides to, who has kids, and they
have, you know, um, uh, savings that they're, you
know, wanting their kids to inherit, and they, um,
They, uh, they decide to go to Las Vegas
and gamble the money, and woohoo, they win. And
now suddenly they're, you know, inheritance of these kids
is, is, you know, quadrupled. Um, BUT still, even
if that turned out to be a good thing
for them to have done in the end because
they lucked out and the, and the roulette wheel,
um, it was not a good decision. It was
a bad idea to do this. Because it was,
it was reckless because from everything they knew before
going to Las Vegas, um, chances were they were
gonna lose the money, right? So, so, the fact
that something turned out to be OK according to
the stipulations of the experiment, doesn't mean that the,
the two siblings had a reason for knowing it
beforehand. So for all these, these reasons, this, this,
uh, uh, this, this finding of moral dumb. Founding,
that's kind of a, a, you know, a, um,
a fundamental fact of our moral um operations, um,
is, is, has, has been rebutted and, and critiqued
and, and I think uh largely debunked at this
point such that there are few people, few, few
psychologists who study, um, you know, uh, moral psychology
who, who take that for, for granted anymore.
OK, so, uh, and why is it that people
from different time periods and different places hold different
sets of moral values, what explains that?
So, so here again, I sort of employ this
kind of tripartite scheme of the uh changes in
concerns, changing in connections, and changing in coordination. So,
oh, I can, well I can go into each,
but, but just the, the, the general um I
The claim of the book is that in order
to understand these moral changes that have happened throughout
history, some of them very radical, with regards to
democratic norms, with regards to slavery, with regards to
public executions, with regards to, to voting rights for
women, um, to understand, uh, why, uh, people, um,
used to accept things that we no longer accept,
we have to understand the psychology of those individuals,
um, at the time. Um, SO, and 11, thing
I talked about at length is, is the sort
of the idea of human equality as a relatively,
um, and the idea of human rights as a
relatively new, uh, discovery or, or new invention as
the historian Lynn Hunt says. Um, SO, so much
of our ideas about, you know, universal human rights,
um, The idea that we shouldn't discriminate against people
based on their race or their gender when it
comes to voting, when it comes to employment, housing,
uh, is based on the idea that humans are
for, um, for all most purposes, um, equal, um,
across, uh, gender and racial, uh, and other lines,
uh, meaning that knowing what somebody's gender is or
somebody's race is doesn't tell us anything about their
capability. For owning a home, for functioning society, for
forming political opinions and so forth. But the, but
the idea of this kind of equality, you know,
is, is really, uh, relatively new and, and, you
know, what seems obvious to us, um, is, was,
was the opposite of obvious, uh, it is obviously
false, not obviously true to a lot of people
living, or most people living in the 16th century,
17th, and even 18th century. Uh, AND what, if
you remove that assumption, um, that people, that, that
people are equal, if you take away the idea,
uh, that people are equal, um, a lot of
the moral views, uh, that we hold today about
voting rights, about, um, basic, um, democratic values in
a fall away, um, or at least are, are,
are severely undermined. Um, SO, and that's one example
of how, uh, people People, um, can, can form,
you know, uh, the, the people in history have
sort of, um, have taken time to develop moral
concerns, for example, with universal human rights, by, by
slowly learning to recognize that we are far more
similar than we might have seemed, have seemed at
one time. And, and sometimes you see these kinds
of, of, of the beliefs and the rights kind
of uh developing, you know, in, in, in You
know, in somewhat asynchronously. So, and one interesting figure
I've talked about in the book is, is Abraham
Lincoln, the, the, the president of the United States
during the Civil War. So Lincoln, um, who's had
this uh very evolving view around a race and
slavery, um, there's a wonderful book by historian Eric
Foner, who, uh, called the, The Fiery Trial about
Lincoln's relationship to, to slavery. And Lincoln, uh, for
most of his life, as far as we, we
know, was opposed to slavery, um, but at the
same time, um, he was, he was, he held
very racist views. He did not think that, that
white and black people were equal. Um, HE came
to, uh, to see them as more equal later
in his life, but initially he did not argue
that they were equal. He just thought that they
were sort of Equal enough to not enslave each
other, meaning that, that black people should not be,
be enslaved. Um, SO, it's, it's by digging into
the psychological realities that these people were living in,
that we can come to understand why what seems
so obvious to us, for example, the idea of
universal human rights, did not seem too obvious to
them. And the point here is not to To
excuse them. I mean, some, in many cases, it's,
you know, I personally think that they should have
known better. I mean think of somebody like Jefferson
who wrote the Declaration of Independence, saying that it
was self-evident that people had inalienable rights, uh, and
yet enslaved, you know, hundreds of people on this
plantation. Um, THEY, I, I have, uh, no interest
in, in sort of, in, in, um, condoning his
behavior, uh, but I think I want to understand
it. I want to understand how his morality works
and the the morality of his contemporaries worked because
it tells us something about human morality. Um, SO
that's the, the project here and, and, uh, to,
to understand that we need to step into their
psychological realities and dig into the particular beliefs they
held, for example, this belief that, that humans were
not equal.
So I mean, do you think that if we
look at things in terms of moral progress or
moral regress, that if in the future even, I
mean, people who are part of our current societies.
Western societies, for example, if somewhere in the future
they find themselves in another, in a new set
of circumstances and even intellectual circumstances that there could
be moral regress.
Uh, YEAH, I mean, I think some people would,
would, uh, say that we're living through the moral
regress now, you know, that, uh, and, and in
fact, the fear of, of moral decline is, is
very widespread, um, so meaning that, that there is
some, some interesting, uh, research by Dan Gilbert and,
um, and, uh, some other, uh, folks about how
there's a, you know, Uh, across multiple societies and
across multiple times, uh, people, uh, on average, feel
that morality in their lifetime is sort of declining,
the moral level of society is declining, sometimes it
peaked around their birth, and then, you know, goes
down. Um, SO there's a lot of, of fear,
uh, that morality is, is getting worse as we
are in the process of regressing, morally speaking. And
then people are engaging in various um efforts to
try to fight that, you know, of course, for,
for in the sort of prototypical conservative view, it's
gonna try to return to an earlier state, uh,
for the more sort of uh left leaning or
progressive views, often it's trying to aspire for a
new kind of uh future that, that, that, that
overcomes the moral flaws of, of our present, um.
But yes, absolutely, I think it's, it's very possible
to, for views that were, um, you know, once
abandoned or thought of as, you know, unthinkable to
sort of gain ascendancy again, um, so, so that's,
I don't think, uh, that, um, you know, the,
the, the arc of the moral history is, is
sort of, is, is always sort of going in,
in one direction, um, and you know, it's, uh,
it. I mean, in empirically, psychologically, and we're, we're
not, as I talk about in the book, we're
not really in a position to say that morality
is, is getting better for these questions of what's
better and what's worse and not really empirical scientific
questions, there are questions for all of us, um,
but even, you know, as, as a, you know,
a person stepping out of my, you know, role
as a researcher and just, you know, evaluating society
around me, I don't see any reason to think
that morality, the moral. You know, standing of society
will always uh move, um, in upwards and upwards.
Uh, THE Obama used to say, he used to
like to quote uh Martin Luther King about the
arc of the moral, the, or the arc of
the moral history or the history arc of the
moral universe, uh, bending towards justice, but, uh, in
that, during that bending, there's a lot of zigging
and zagging as well. So that seems, you know,
very plausible to me, and I don't, and, and
I think Um, we, we need to use the
evidence, uh, from psychology to try to make sense
of that, to try to understand why is it
that, uh, we are, uh, having kind of reactionary
movements, for example, feeling that why, uh, do a
lot of people, uh, feel on, on the, uh,
on the political right, um, in the United States
right now feel like, uh, the progressive movement, uh,
went too far around the, you know, during the,
um, The, uh, the Biden administration, for example, why,
why there is this kind of counter reaction, and
I think that one, you know, role of, of
science and, and of psychological science and morality in
particular is to make sense of those kinds of
counter reactions, uh, without, you know, necessarily, but it's
not our job to pass judgments on them as,
as, as researchers, but to try to make sense
of them.
So I mean many times people ask themselves and
other people why certain things that we tend to
them as being atrocities happen and why sometimes A
huge number of people seem to participate in them.
So let's just pick the example of the Rwandan
genocide in 1994. I mean, do the psychology have
an explanation for that as to why perhaps in
certain circumstances people would be willing to participate in
those kinds of acts?
Yeah, I, I do think that, that psychology has
something important to say about that. And in, in
fact, you know, really since the, since World War
II, a lot of psychology has been dedicated specifically
to try to understand these kinds of atrocities, how
they happen, why they happen, how to prevent them,
and, and so forth. And I do think, you
know, morality, excuse me. Morality isn't, uh, the full
story there, but it's part of the story, you
know, uh, and it's not the full story because
people sometimes engaged in atrocities that they know to
be wrong at the time, but they're not, they
nonetheless feel pressured to do so, so, you know,
my point isn't that people always do what they
think is, is morally right, um, but morality is,
is part of the story. Because, uh, if people,
um, see themselves as having a moral license to,
um, commit atrocities, uh, or at least thinking, finding
it less condemnable or more acceptable to commit mass
murder and to attack their neighbors, of course, they're
gonna be more likely to do so. And, uh,
the, I think the, the, what we know about,
uh, when these kinds of genocidal, um, Horrors happen.
Um, IT is, uh, very often, uh, when people,
when, when enough people have been put in a
position where they, where they think that they are
under threat, that they think that they're under attack,
you know, this is clearly, um, the case of,
of, uh, in the Iranian genocide, and even, you
know, in the, uh, in, in, in, in Nazi
Germany leading up to World War II, um, Jews
were, were Presented as a, uh, threat to German
society and to the German nation, and a threat
that needed to be eliminated. So, um, and you
know, it's a wide-held principle in, in morality, uh,
that people have some rights to self-defense, and you
could see that the, the leaders of these kinds
of genocidal, um, movements and genocidal projects are using,
are leveraging that principle of self-defense to an Extreme
degree by portraying some group that in reality isn't
poses no threat, of course, to society, um, but,
um, to present that community as a threat that
needs to be, um, uh, be fought before they
come and, and, and take over before they, they,
they, they, they ruin us. Um, SO I think
that, that, that moral psychology absolutely can help us
make sense of that, you know, another thing. Of
course, there is also the idea of, of dehumanization,
which we also see a lot of dehumanizing, you
know, um, rhetoric and the, with the, in, in
those, um, instances, those, those genocides we've talked about
now, uh, where people, you know, describe where the,
the, the attackers, um, describe the other, the victims
as, as vermin or as cockroaches and using other
kinds of animalistic language. Well that's That's playing on
the sort of the, the idea that humans are
not equal, right? This, this, this, this idea that,
uh, that, you know, what still is now much
more accepted than it used to be, but still
not accepted by everybody that, that humans are basically
equal when it comes to fundamental rights. Um, YOU
know, obviously in, in the case of, of Nazi
Germany, which I know a little more about than
the Rwandan case, um, there was, there was, there
was an explicit theory that, uh, some people were
less human, less worth, uh, than others, that the
Jewish people were sort of a lesser kind of
human than the, the Aryan, um, people, and that
that gave the Aryan people a right to kind
of to, to, to abuse or to throw out
the, the, the Jewish people who had fewer rights.
So, yes, in a sense, we've acquired an idea
of human equality, more so, it's more widespread now
in the 21st century or even the 20th century
than it was in the 18th or, or 17th
century. Uh, BUT, uh, it's not, uh, completely there,
and it certainly wasn't completely there early in the,
um, in the 20th century where, you know, ideas
of, of racial differences were widespread, not just in
Nazi Germany, but in the United States and Britain,
and lots of places around the world where people
had the idea that racial differences were so great
that uh they came with, with different rights to
self-determination, for example.
But I mean those circumstances that lead people to
participate in, for example, a genocide, anyone could find
themselves in those circumstances, right? I mean, no one,
or I mean anyone could be susceptible to that
in a more voluntary or a more coerced way,
correct?
Well, I, I don't know if we could say
that just anybody would participate in, in genocide. Uh,
I think that, uh, there, there are, you know,
books and, and big debates that we don't have
to get into here about that, about a particular
personalities that, that go along with this, you know,
for example, there's been, there was a debate between
uh Browning and, and Goldhagen regarding the, these police
battalions that were killing, um, Jews in, in, in
Poland and Eastern Europe, and whether they were, you
know, particular, you know, personalities or not, um. Uh,
THERE was the, there's work by, you know, the,
the old classic work by Theodore Adorno and his
colleagues about the authoritarian personality. So, there are, you
know, real questions about whether there are some people
who are more susceptible to participate in these kinds
of attacks than others, um, but we could, we
could see that they're in a, under some psychological
conditions, you will have more people willing to engage
in these, and one of the conditions. Uh, THAT
enable, uh, a, you know, or heighten the possibility,
the probability of a kind of, um, genocidal attack
or, or, or otherwise a kind of exclusion of
a whole group of people based on race is
when you have a whole country that to a
lesser or greater degree, um, embraces the idea that
humans are not equal. And if you have a
society where it's widely believed that some groups of,
of humans are, are, are. Elevated above others, that
is a risk factor, a desire level for a
kind of um uh uh attack against the, the,
the group deemed lesser, right? So, so that, um,
that weakens, and, and, you know, that is a
much broader, you know, broad, that was, that was
in, in Germany and many other places, much more
broadly held, held view. There were a lot of
people who, who were not, you know, actively participating
in, in the um In the, um, you know,
expulsion and extermination of, of Jewish people during World
War II, who were nonetheless, you know, anti-Semitic, um,
and that was, you know, part of the, the
what made it possible, um, the what made the,
the horrors possible.
Right, so, uh, there's a, I, I mean this
discussion has been going on forever, but and uh
I don't know if it will be solved, it
will ever be solved, but, um, there's a discussion
in moral philosophy and ethics, uh, as to whether
there are really any objective moral truths out there.
I mean, people who I think there are usually
fall on the side of moral realism and people
who think there aren't fall on the side of
moral anti-realism. Do you think that moral psychology and
developmental psychology can contribute to that discussion?
Well, I, I don't think that, uh, moral, uh,
psychology and empirical science can tell us whether there
are, are objective, uh, moral truths, um, because, uh,
the question of moral, uh, truths is not an,
an empirical scientific question, you know, there's been something
recognized by philosophers for a long time from, from
Kant or Hume and, and, um. And others, um,
that you can't, you know, prove with empirical methods
that, you know, something is morally right or morally
wrong. Um, THAT doesn't mean that there is no
objective truth, it's just not, you know, something science
can, can tell us. Uh, WHAT science, the science
of morality can tell us, um, is that, is
whether People believe uh that there are objective moral
truths and you know with regards to very, at
least very basic moral truths, um, uh, people do
believe that, so for example, the, the, the work
by Jeff Goodwin and others finding that most people
are objectivists when it comes to things like, you
know, it's wrong to harm somebody for no reason,
for example, um, but, um. What's, uh, psychology, uh,
can also show us is that there are certain
moral views that are very widely held, and you
know they tend to be the very ones that
I was just alluding to, uh, meaning that, you
know, people everywhere, uh, think it's wrong to engage
in unprovoked violence. Uh, THIS is not, you know,
uniquely Western or American or any other kind of
value, but this is a widely held view. Um,
SO, so, and I think both of those findings,
both the people that have embraced objectivist views and
especially the fact that Excuse me, um, that, um,
these, uh, certain moral, fundamental moral values are, um,
universally shared or near universally shared, um, that, you
know, can, can feed into, inform the debate about
whether there are objective moral truths, and it seem
to make, you know, the case easier for the,
uh, philosophers and, and other people who are, who
are debating this, uh, if there is some kind
of, uh, if there are certain, um, Uh, the
fact that there are certain moral views that are
so widely shared, uh, that seems to make it
easier to, to make the case that there are
objective moral truths, but uh, there's always an extra
step, you know, it's never simply an empirical scientific
question whether such truths, uh, exist, and I happen
to believe them, believe that they are objective moral
truths, but I don't believe that, you know, that
I prove, can prove that in my research.
Right. I mean, let me just ask you one
last question, because I, I mean, I see a
lot of this when I have discussions or conversations
on the show with moral philosophers and ethicists particularly.
Um, I mean, earlier we talked about post hoc
rationalization. Uh, SOMETIMES I, I have the sense that,
uh, for example, philosopher moral philosophers already have a
conclusion in mind when it comes to, uh, a
particular moral truth or what a particular moral truth
is, and then they just Work backwards in terms
of coming up with explanations as to why that
moral truth is a moral truth basically. So because
I mean sometimes I keep asking them, OK, so
why, OK, so what supports that moral truth, and
I know it. Uh, IT'S this, and then, OK,
so why is that true and then it's that,
it's that, it's that, and then we always arrive
at the point where, I mean, you just have
to accept as a fact that a particular, uh,
premise is correct because you uh there's not, you
can't go further backwards to explain, I mean you
just have to. TO accept it as a moral
principle basically. So do you think that there's perhaps
anything coming from moral psychology that would have anything
to add to that? I mean to explain where
the reasons that people give for their Uh, moral
values, where, where they come from at the end
of the day and whether that also applies to
moral philosophers and ethicists and perhaps there could be
some sort of, uh, I don't know, post hoc
rationalization and when it comes to developing a moral
system or something like that.
Interesting. Yes, so, and, first of all, um, I
don't think that the evidence supports the idea, supports
the idea that, that people are routinely, uh, forming
their moral views on automatic grounds, and then they're
coming up with post-op rationalizations after. I don't think
there's much evidence for that. Um, WITH respect to
how moral philosophers operate, uh, I, I mean, I,
I, I remember I was speaking to a colleague,
a friend of mine who's a moral philosopher who's
saying, well, there, there, there is a sort of
a school of, of thought and philosopher we use
it, you, you take the most extreme position you
can argue, you can responsibly argue for, or you
can sort of sensibly argue for as a kind.
Of just uh an intellectual project and for, and
I still wouldn't call that, uh, post hoc rationalization
in the sort of in the general sense, uh,
or in the sort of in the pejorative sense
because there's still a sort of reasoning, uh, but,
but yes, they are sort of perhaps you know
seeking out a position and then you know, trying
to buttress that with the strongest possible arguments, um.
I think it's to, to understand and excuse me,
and relate the, the, you know, the ordinary, you
know, moral reasoning that we all engage in from
the sort of project of moral philosophy. Now it's,
it's Important to recognize that, you know, in, in
the ordinary moral functioning that we all engage in,
um, contradictions are sort of like just part of
the game, you know, that, that we have moral
principles that are just intention and there's no easy
way to resolve them, and I, I don't think
it's because they're irrational. I think It's because the
world is complicated, uh, you know, I wouldn't take
the fact that in, in physics, uh, I think
it still is the case that, that they have,
you know, the, the wave, uh, uh, view of
light and the, the wave theory light and the
particle theory light are, you know, seemingly in contradiction,
but I don't think that's because physicists are irrational.
I think it's because it's a complicated phenomenon. In
philosophy, uh, there is a pressure for internal consistency,
and there is a project of seeing, can we
demonstrate that. All moral principles can be subsumed either
descriptively or prescriptively under a single uh principle, uh,
such as the utilitarian maxim of, of, you know,
of maximizing, uh, net welfare or the categorical imperative
or some other kind of, uh, recipe for, for
morality. Um, THAT is a, you know, distinct, uh,
Project, uh, where that, that where you are, you
know, trying to see, OK, what's, OK, if, if
this is, you know, this is conspris like if
this is, these are moral truths, how is that
possible, right? How can we demonstrate that this is
a, that this is a sort of epistemological possible
thing to make these kind of IPR what he
called a priori synthetic judgments about right and wrong
ways of, of acting, um, so. I think it's,
uh, the, the, to me, the, the, the scientific
uh project, uh, uh, or the, the scholarly project
of moral philosophy in those cases is more akin
to, um, hypothesis testing in empirical science where you
have some hypothesis, like I think this is, you
know, this might be true, and now let's explore
if the evidence or in the philosopher's case, the
arguments support it. Um, SO, I guess you could
call it. Post hoc reasoning because, you know, there,
there's an hypothesis that's then, that, that, that's, that's
then being explored, uh, but uh again I wouldn't,
if that is post hoc rationalization, then you know,
I wouldn't use it as a pejorative thing. I
would use it as a, as a sincere intellectual
project to try to see what can we prove,
um, uh, what's the conjecture and that's yet to
be proved in mathematics or in moral philosophy and
what can we actually demonstrate.
Right. OK, so the book is again Between Fixed
and fickle, Why Our Moral Views Keep Changing. I'm
of course leaving a link to it in the
description of the interview, and Dr. Dah, just before
we go, would you like to tell people where
they can find you and your work on the
internet?
Uh, WELL, the, the, uh, you mean my URL,
my, my web, uh,
yeah, if you have a website, social media, and
so on, yeah,
yeah, so I definitely have a web page. We
have our lab has a webpage, uh, that you
can Google. It's called the Developmental Moral Psychology Lab,
and I have a web page at the, uh,
at, at the, um, homepage of the Cornell Psychology.
DEPARTMENT that where you can find me. So if
you Google me, you'll, you'll find that. I'm not
on social media, to my credit, I think. Uh,
SO you won't find me there, at least in
any interesting sense. Uh, BUT yeah, uh, do feel
free to reach out. I'd love, I always love
to hear from people and, and see how they
react to the book. So thank you very much
for, for having me here and, and for anyone
who's listening.
Well, thank you so much for doing this. It's
been a fascinating, a fascinating conversation.
Thank
you. Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview
until the end. If you liked it, please share
it, leave a like and hit the subscription button.
The show is brought to you by Enlights Learning
and Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com
and also please consider supporting the show on Patreon
or PayPal. I would also like to give a
huge thank you to my main patrons and PayPal
supporters, Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz
Olaf, Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim
Hollis, Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst Connolly. Then
Dmitri Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield,
Governor, Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo,
and Hal Herzognun, Machael Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and
Samuel Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel,
Sardusran, David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego
Londono Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro,
Adam Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltonin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolati, Gabriel Pancortez
or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.